the search for lives has now become a
search to honor the Dead
the United Nations says the current
death toll could be double and under
this Rubble are the bodies yet to be
counted
in guarding this site since the
earthquake
[Music]
they've retrieved dozens of family
members 14 of them have died including
two young sisters they're now looking
for the Third
now it is very very unlikely that she's
still alive that they want to take the
body so that she can get a proper burial
back in Syria
corpses are being pulled out all around
us
if this one isn't identified it will be
buried in a mass grave just outside of
town
lost in the chaos of This Disaster
family stand watched to ensure their
loved ones don't meet the same fate
they're still pulling out people a full
week on and the air is just full of the
smell of decomposing bodies
Muhammad says they've had to enjoy the
smell while searching
this is the smell of countless bodies
swelling under the sun on the seventh
day he says
[Music]
and this is why we honor the Dead with a
burial
after days of digging the buildings no
longer have any form or structure
making the search for victims even
harder
it's an exhausting effort
and one with no end in sight
the site is flattened and the chances of
recovering the body of third sister are
slim Muhammad turns his attention to a
neighboring building where his
three-year-old cousin is still missing
as syrians our return is to our land to
our country to be buried with our family
he says
and so he keeps on looking
with the same dedication no matter if
they're dead or if they're alive
Sky News